[Music]
David your whole life people have told
you you were sick I'll show you that it
was really just a lie the human race
beginning to evolve the divisions were
created by our government to track and
study people like you and the ones they
can't control they kill they're looking
for us
I could help you rewrite the story of
your life
shall we begin
no I can't you're the key key to what
winning the war this is real
[Music]
you have an extremely large amygdala
thank you
hey youtubers is Charlie new x-men
Legion footage x-men Breaking Bad for
the most powerful mutant in the universe
and new logan trailer of it's coming
that I'll explain there will be a weekly
giveaway just like the Deadpool giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it's a $20 Amazon gift card I'll
announce winners at the end of this so
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so if you have no idea what's going on
Legion is a new FX TV show based on the
x-men universe of characters like the
most powerful mutant in existence not
counting the Phoenix force technically
the Phoenix force is a cosmic entity so
you know number 10 this is based on the
Legion character David Haller
who's the son of Professor X and a
character named Gabriel Haller
who you might not be familiar with but
in the comics she was just somebody that
Professor X rescued from being catatonic
using his abilities they fell in love
had a child the way they're pitching the
show is that it's sort of like x-men
Breaking Bad in West world for the most
powerful mutant character it's only
eight episodes so it's kind of like a
miniseries it's all about the dawn of
his abilities him learning about mutants
the fact that he is a mutant what his
powers are so number nine in the comics
he actually debuted as a villain in the
new mutants comic book remember that's
the comic book that Deadpool in cable
both debuted but he's typically
presented as an antihero because he's so
powerful it drives him insane because
his powers sort of flow from Professor X
it's sort of like an evolution of that
in the way that Jean Grey can't fully
control the Phoenix force so he has all
these different personalities and each
one of them is capable of manifesting a
different mutant ability so he has all
these abilities inside of him almost
limitless potential but he can only use
one of them at a time depending on which
personality it is and sometimes there
are evil personalities sometimes they're
nice personalities so he's the kind of
person that Wolverine wouldn't even try
to touch just like you are way too crazy
for me so that's why you see this set in
and around a mental institution so think
of it is like Breaking Bad he's a normal
person who's just trying to deal with a
mental illness but then he discovers why
he's having all these crazy visions is
because of his ability
Odie's so the love interest that you've
been seeing in the trailers this woman
here that he runs into is a woman named
Sid who also seems to have the ability
to swap consciousness with people
later they fall in love and he finds out
that she was taken by a group of people
so you see Melanie here played by Jean
smart I like the white it makes you
think of Emma Frost because this is said
in the 70s you're thinking about first
class era so you're thinking about first
class characters like the Hellfire Club
but she's one of the therapists inside
this mental institution he has a sister
that he cares about who's trying to help
him on the outside most of you are
probably familiar with Aubrey Plaza
she plays Lenny one of his friends who
sort of this recovering alcoholic that's
also stuck in the institution that tries
to help him out day to day but you can
kind of see how the series is mostly
about him questioning what reality is in
the comics his code name Legion actually
refers to the Legion of personalities
that he contains inside of him so he
himself is like this Legion of abilities
he's super powerful but he just batshit
crazy so think of him as the Walter
White of comic book characters and they
did say that they had their run of the
x-men universe they basically set this
like in a different multiverse so that
they can explain how he's capable of
being Professor X's child but James
McAvoy is playing him in the movies
right now so it's much younger so there
aren't any issues with the timeline you
have to imagine that Patrick Stewart's
Professor X that would fit a little bit
better with the timeline so there are a
lot of x-men characters out there
they've teased that the world knows
about mutants so they're probably going
to be a couple evil organizations like
the Hellfire Club with their eyes on him
along with the US government so in the
comics a lot of the fun of this is him
trying to control his more evil
personalities remember each one of his
personalities is very very powerful but
some of them are really bad so at any
given time you have the good ones that
are at war with the bad ones all within
him so this way they're billing this
series is this psychological drama with
a lot of x-men action in it the series
itself doesn't start till February 8th
so it's going to be a Wednesday night
show probably 9:00 p.m. so the videos I
do for it won't post till Thursday but I
feel like this will actually be
a solid for those of you that are
looking for like a really hardcore x-men
series but everybody's saying that this
is gonna be really solid it's made by
the same person that made Fargo which is
winning all those crazy awards so the
Marvel people have been hyping it up is
this crazy cable show with all this
awesome stuff that they would never be
able to do on network like with agents
of shield what they'll probably do is
drop a couple more trailers before
premieres so I'll do videos for that
just to remind people that it's coming
but I feel like it'll fit into the
scheduling nicely because legends of
tomorrow which used to be a Thursday
show is now a Tuesday show so my
schedules changed a little bit so now
Thursday's a little more open so give me
all your questions about Legion like
what are you guys most excited about if
you've never read the Legion character
he's a relatively smaller character even
though he's one of the bigger more
powerful ones he showed up during
Avengers x-men access he's just like so
powerful that it's harder to write
characters like that because it's hard
to find obstacles for them but he
himself is his own obstacle just because
of his personalities they're at war with
each other so I'm just really excited
for this to get batshit crazy so if
you're looking for a really intense show
to fill the void that Westworld Game of
Thrones Breaking Bad those shows have
left then this is it and it'll actually
fill the gap before the Marvel Netflix
series start to because those don't
start up till March so there's gonna be
a whole lot of really awesome Marvel TV
happening this spring DC TV is great
Marvel TV is just getting started in the
biggest thing is that there's a new
Wolverine trailer that's dropping this
Thursday so of course I'll do a video
for it because the movies coming out in
a little over a month it's probably a
little more story based so we'll learn
more about what the actual story of
Logan is is sort of like a
post-apocalyptic story where mutant kind
is died off and he's hiding out on the
Mexican border with Professor X when the
Laura
x-23 character comes running to them
seeking shelter from what seems like the
Reavers that seems like this evil group
of people but I'll talk about that when
I post that Logan trailer later this
week congratulations to the new Deadpool
giveaway winner Brussels sprouts please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so we can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a
Deadpool or Legion
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about what's
going on with Deadpool 2 in the other
x-men movies and you can click here to
rewatch that Logan red band trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight